so do you want to defend yourself now
that you're here yeah so I'd like to
explain okay I I hate part four and the
only part of part four I Hate's a strong
word so I'm Not A Slice of Life guy did
you watch all of it yeah okay I've given
I like Parts one two and five I love
part five as well okay so part five
slaps that was this opinion predated
part five yes yeah but part four it's my
least favorite genre of all Slice of
Life it was like all Slice of Life until
Kira and then it was right right so it
finishes strong and I hated everything
before it
okay I can I can kind of respect that
because I I think okay here's here's the
dichotomy right because I I agree with
you that the beginning of part four I'm
also not a slice of Life man it's slow
it's very very slow but I think the best
JoJo has been so far anime wise is like
the second part of part four because
when Kira gets introduced it's so cool
yeah I agree I like Kira a lot but I
don't think he said it wasn't enough
I was so [ __ ] bored of seeing them
just like walk around the city like the
manga artist and trying [ __ ] was so
important
yeah I couldn't stand it okay so
what didn't you like about part three I
was just like gonna get there part three
I didn't hate nearly as much as part
four I like I actually liked all the
characters I just thought there was a
lot of times where it just became the
same formula it was very long it was
very much like I dragged so much yeah it
was very much like a monster of the week
type of thing yeah which I think a lot
of Jojo fans also weren't a huge fan of
but so you see that that that's not the
thing that like surprised me but like
you say you prefer part one over yeah
yeah okay
that was the opinion right I totally
agree with these tanks but it was just
like then then you say oh yeah part
one's better so we all watched part one
but like please sell us on part one so
part one is like you classic like
grown-up nostalgic anime right you have
your right
which is fine and cool that's what
you're used to yeah it's not trying to
do anything different but the style is
great I think JoJo Style's always been
really good yeah and I think it works
well with Jamon I love when they
introduce Dio he comes out of the gate
like this [ __ ] Menace like he's
ripping heads off and [ __ ] like he's
cool and it's short it's not long so you
get like a very tight burst of like what
you're expecting right right so I wasn't
you know like offended I enjoyed it
don't you think that like part one was
just like a little bit too like shaky
and a lot there's even like the pots
from like episode like
three to five that were just like
because I feel like part one is like
Iraqi I feel didn't quite know where he
wanted to take it JoJo the Frog had wine
yeah it's like that's all cool and all
but it's like it didn't really like flow
as a story in mind I agree and it
definitely wasn't the narrative wasn't
like the strong part one but I just
really enjoyed that it was pretty
unashamedly anime trophy yeah yeah like
it had pretty much every anime cliche
for its time but yeah you definitely
practiced this argument
every explain to yourself pretty well
yeah I just yeah even even with that in
mind I just can't the last part of part
four was so strong that I don't think I
could even I like I think part four is
better than three two one and five can
we all agree part two [ __ ] slaps of
course of course yeah I think part two
is like I wish part two was part one so
then that would be the introduction yeah
because part one sometimes puts people
off because it's really odd and didn't
quite hit the feel for the well you know
part two he kind of figures out what he
wants to do with Jojo and he kind of
gets more campy with it right it's more
fun and he lets the characters be weird
whereas part one he's kind of like kind
of still sticking to traditional
character archetypes except for dear
he's just weird yeah and dear has always
been really weird I guess that's why
he's reused him like 19 times yeah yeah
because I think what really sold me on
jojo in general was actually when Part
Two started because I saw part one I
just thought Jonathan was like a really
really boring main character and I
thought is all of Jojo gonna be like
this and then you see Joseph and you're
like holy [ __ ] yeah this is so much fun
now oh my God I know the Tommy Gun when
he wears the Tommy Gun yeah oh this is
not gonna be a normal show yeah when he
was doing the training and climbing up
that [ __ ] pillar I don't know
everything about that yeah
unreasonably hype for something kind of
like smaller and just a weird insert of
him just staring at his mom in the back
and it's like why would this be like in
like this does not fit thematically with
anything that has happened for me it was
for me it was like right at the very
very beginning like chapter one of them
to where like he takes the card yeah the
coke bottle like fears immediately I was
just like yeah racism is
oh
she's like okay but real question though
now that we've like kind of all caught
up and you know you obviously watch part
five right yep have you watched part six
I've started it and then I haven't
watched the second part of part six
because the Netflix releases
yeah I know it's great part six I think
so everything I've seen so far is good
yeah plastic is fantastic yeah where
would you put pop five in in the higher
part five would be right behind part two
but just barely better than one two and
three four so it'd be two five yeah two
five eight I haven't finished six so I
can't scale that yet but six is better
than two then one three and four so far
for me the only thing that really holds
back five is sure no he's kind of boring
I didn't think so I thought it was right
I don't know I feel like every other
character is more interesting than Jonah
I mean the the side characters
definitely like yeah is the main
character that should have been yeah
yeah is like carries the whole thing and
then the other boys are a bit more you
know he feels like he's kind of more
jonathan-esque like he had a bit more
character in the star where he was kind
of more conniving and then he kind of
drops it real quick when Bridge ready
turns out I I feel though that's like a
very common trade with JoJo because like
even in part one like it just definitely
is way more interesting of a character
than John yeah
that was amazing see I hold that opinion
for part three because I thought Joe
throw is a bit more of like the more
cleaner JoJo yeah just just the dude bro
can you like can do everything perfectly
but like the entire crew or part three
is what sells it for me it's like The
Ensemble yeah I agree I hated polaro
after the first time I watched it I
wasn't a fan carried it for me
of course I loved Polaris right I know
people love him yeah and it was the kind
of fun afterwards where I'm like yeah I
think I like it looking back yeah but if
I watched it again I think I would be
like no yeah no that makes sense that
makes sense
it's way too long wait oh [ __ ] I'm
constantly impressed with the sheer
amount of stuff you watch I watch pretty
much everything yeah okay it blows my
mind your schedule must be stupid like
how do you watch all this and then you
you review every movie that I swear that
comes out and then you uploading twice a
day you're streaming all day are you
like on second monitor while streaming
you watching [ __ ] no man I don't know I
stay up late like three a.m and I have
been since like college but I've always
found like there's always enough time as
long as you're having fun yeah time
moves for me like time moves slower when
I'm having fun so I feel like I have
more time to do [ __ ] yeah because I
swear to God you watch more anime than
like most of us also you review more
anime yeah
you're definitely running like anime
YouTube
because you're doing that on top of
everything else you're doing like yeah
yeah I would like to know your secret
because I've been watching like doing
anime as a job for like [ __ ] five
years now and I'm like struggling at
this point because it's just just so
much [ __ ] it's all coming out at once
too which is a little rough because
you're having because like it's all
coming from different places like
Netflix size JoJo's part six and they've
got a terrible release schedule yeah
they admitted overlaps with other [ __ ]
that have come out seasonally yeah so I
don't know it gets convoluted